[Captioned via Y Translator]
This video is sponsored
by NordVPN.
Molten metal in a vacuum
chamber, what happens to it?
Will it bubble
and boil like water?
Will it hold its heat
for a really long time?
We're going to find out.
[Music]
For years,
we have done experiments
using a vacuum chamber,
and we've done experiments
using molten metal,
and today, for the first time,
we're going to see what happens
if we put molten metal
into a vacuum chamber.
Here's what we're going to try.
We've got two cups
of equal amounts of aluminum.
We're going to melt
them both down.
One of them will go
inside a vacuum chamber,
and one of them will sit
outside the vacuum chamber.
Let's find out what
happens differently.
We've got these two steel cups,
and we're going to put these
into our furnace,
and melt down
the aluminum inside them.
They started off
as the same cup.
We cut this one in half just
so that we can see
inside it better.
We just want
to watch what happens
inside our vacuum chamber,
and visions going to be
a little bit limited.
This one's going to be
outside the vacuum chamber,
so we should be able to see
into it just fine anyway.
We've also got on the lid
of our vacuum chamber,
it's digital thermometer
that goes up to about 1900
degrees Fahrenheit,
or just over 1,000
degrees Celsius.
What we're going to do
is tape that switch down,
and set it on so that
as we pull out the vacuum
and leave it in a vacuum,
it is giving us
a constant readout
of the temperature of the metal.
Hopefully,
that will let us see how fast
or slow the metal cools down.
[Music]
I think we're going
to call that good.
[Music]
Thermometer,
which is still attached to this lid,
actually only showing a temperature
of about 500 degrees Fahrenheit.
A little bit more depending
on the angle I get.
I think it's probably kind
of hard to read aluminum,
which is very shiny in places.
It might struggle with that.
Aluminum isn't liquid
at 500 Fahrenheit.
So that's probably
not a perfect representation,
but it is going to give us
a comparison between the two.
Aluminum's definitely
cooling down.
It's now at that stage
that's weirdly clay like.
I can stab into it
with a little bit of pressure,
but it's definitely not liquid.
[Music]
Still showing a span
of around 350 to 400 Fahrenheit.
Lets see if I get the same result with this one.
Yeah, 35 to 410-450,
and this is only been going
for maybe five minutes
out of the furnace.
Order of operations, I'm going
to tape down the trigger.
I'm going to pull out the metal
cup full of molten aluminum,
set it on the brick,
throw the lid on,
and then turn on the vacuum.
[Music]
Metal in the chamber.
We're suddenly getting a very
high temperature reading.
All right,
we are lowering the pressure
in the vacuum chamber.
Oh, no, our thermometer
just turned off.
[Music]
The aluminum is putting off
so much heat, it heated up
the electrical tape,
which got loose,
and let go of our button.
[Music]
It's going to come off
again, I think.
I think I even saw a couple
of bubbles coming up
out of the aluminum there.
Our thermometer
did turn off again.
It was reading about
435 when it turned off,
but that aluminum
is bubbling, just a little bit.
I'll admit, I did not think
we are going to get
any bubbling from our metal.
I've never seen
molten aluminum bubble
the way it's doing right now,
as it cool down.
So, I think this is the vacuum
that's causing that.
The glass has actually
heated up a lot.
It's really hot to the touch.
[Music]
Oh no, see if it still works.
Error.
This whole thing is really hot.
[Music]
Hello-- Oh man, that is bright.
Okay, the--
Let's go in the shade.
Didn't think this through.
We're good.
Okay.
Hello!
Are people trying to steal
the data on your computer?
We got to talk
about our sponsor real quick,
and hang on, don't go away.
This is something a lot
of you might actually
be interested in.
Our sponsor for today's
video is NordVPN.
That's a virtual
private Network.
It's a company that secures
the data on your phones,
computers,
your Internet devices.
And along with security,
they offer some other really
cool features.
My favorite thing about it
for example is the fact
that I can reroute my traffic
through kind of all over
anywhere in the world.
So, if I want to see what's
on like some streaming services
outside of where I usually live,
I can redirect my traffic
through a different country,
and then my favorite
streaming platforms
will show different content
based on what country
it's going through.
That's pretty cool.
In addition to that,
it does provide security.
If I'm connecting to a Wi-Fi
somewhere in public,
like at a fast food restaurant
or a hotel or something like that,
there are a lot
of people out there
who are trying to do bad things.
They're trying
to steal your data.
They want your information
off of your devices,
and they're going to try
and do that.
Well with NordVPN,
you don't have to worry.
Your information is safe.
It's secure.
People aren't going
to be stealing stuff
off of your computer
because NordVPN provides
so much security for you.
If you're someone
who likes security,
or if you're someone who likes
to have your internet traffic
anonymous and untraceable,
or if you're someone who
likes to stream content,
from other places,
NordVPN is something
you should definitely get.
You can get a great deal
right now by going
to NordVPN.com/random,
and using the promo code
RANDOM to get 75%
off of three year plan,
plus a free month.
You want to stay safe online,
NordVPN has got you covered.
Now, let's get back to checking
out our vacuumed metal.
I want to try
and get both
of these pieces of aluminum out,
and see what differences
I can find.
So, let's see
if we can separate them.
[Music]
Here we go.
All right.
So this is interesting.
This is sort
of some pieces
of the aluminum that melted,
but I never stirred the aluminum
on top of it.
So you can just sort of see
the stick formation left.
This one seems
to have more pitting
and bubbling on the bottom,
and again, this is
the one that was
in the vacuum chamber,
and this is the one
that was not.
I think I want to cut both
of these in half,
and see if there's
any difference
on the inside.
[Music]
I would say on the inside,
they look pretty much the same,
at least, when you cut them
in half with a hacksaw.
So what did we get
out of putting molten metal
in the vacuum chamber?
The surface definitely
cooled down differently.
The one that we put
in the vacuum chamber
has a lot more pits,
a lot more strange angles to it,
and overall,
just a very different texture.
The one that was
in the vacuum chamber, is more
of a flat, silvery
aluminum color.
Maybe we have a different sort
of aluminum oxide that's formed,
different composition,
different speed that it formed.
It's pretty much the same colors
on what's on the edge
of this one here.
This one's the same color
pretty much all the way across,
except for a little bit
of slag here in the corner.
And then of course,
what surprised me the most is
that while it was
in the vacuum chamber,
it seemed to have
bubbles rising up out of it.
I was also amazed at how
much heat it put off.
The outside of that vacuum
chamber got really hot.
We did have, something
of a casualty of war.
This is the thermometer that
I was trying to use,
and it seems to have
an issue scanning
the surface of aluminum.
It wasn't really giving
us an accurate reading.
It was only giving us a reading
of about 450 degrees Fahrenheit
while the aluminum
was still molten,
and aluminum does not melt
that temperature.
So unfortunately,
this is not the best way
to measure the temperature
of molten aluminum.
We're going to have to look
into that a little bit later.
Maybe we can find
a thermocouple
that actually goes down
into the aluminum
to measure it there.
So we may have to revisit
this experiment later
on when we have a little bit
more industrial equipment
that can handle some
of these temperatures.
Also, thanks again
to our sponsor NordVPN.
Click the link
in the description
to go to NordVPN.com/random,
and use the promo code
RANDOM to get 75%
off of a three-year plan.
Guys, that's not all,
we've got more for you see.
That box will take you directly
to our most recent video,
and you check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you hit this bomb,
you'll be subscribe to our channel,
so you never miss out
on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.